what's up white dude with the Jordan
sitting in the light so
everybody can see him I got you what do
you do for a living man you got a lot of
swagger for a gay
doctor you are a very confident
homosexual doctor dude when you tell
people you're the nurse older white dude
used to the world as certain way what
does he
sayhe he said that cuz he wants me to
feel bad my job is to make these
laugh not care about them
kids them kids I hope nobody clap
for you during Co we got that clapping
didn't we he said he was a nurse
and everybody's like come on this is
your wife you know why I like her cuz
she don't like me I'm dead serious if
she was laughing real hard I'd have been
like she ain't really to be honest
with you she hates me because I
called you a gay doctor and I love that
about her only she gets to call you gay
not
me